هل نتوقع تحقيقا شفافا بعد الحصول على
الصندوقين الاسوددين نحن بنامل لتحقيق جيد
لكن بصراحه فان التاريخ يقترحوا امثله عده
حيث حصل فيها تحطم غامض للكثير من
الطائرات حيث هنالك رجال مهمين من النساء
من رجال الاعمال من الثوار ايضا هم خسروا
حياتهم في حوادث وظروف غامضه هو ملف اظنه
متواصل سوف نكتشفه الكثيره من حيثيته
وسيبقى الكثير ايضا مخفيه
انه سيكون هنالك الكثير من المقاربات اجل
الاشخاص الذين هم ضد بوتين يدعمون ويقولون
انه كان وراء مقتل البريكو جيد لكن
بالاشخاص الذين يدعمون بوتين في روسيا فان
الامر هو ربما يمثل اظهارا وعرضا للاراده
السياسيه انه لا يمكن مسامحه اي شخص
لتنظيمه ربما انقلاب في روسيا كان لافتا
ما قاله الرئيس بيلاروسي من انه علم
بمحاوله اغتيال وابلغ بوتين وبوتين ابلغ
ليس في ذلك محاوله لابعاد اي شكوك عن
بوتين
ربما ربما هذه هي الطريقه
لابعاد الرئيس بوتين عن اي شبهه وايضا هي
طريقه الرئيس بيلاروسيا من اجل انقاذ ماء
يوجهه ربما وسائل الاعلام الغربيه ستلقي
اللوم على روسيا وهذا هو السير طبيعي
للاحداث التركيز سيكون على ما اذا كان
هيكل ادفاجنر ستتاثر
وهل سيمكن ضمها الى الجيش الروسي املاه هل
ستقاتل في اوكرانيا ام لا هل ستكون ناجحه
في افريقيا ام لا اذا لا شك بان الدول
التي
فيها وجود تطرح تساؤلات
حول مصير العلاقه ونوعها وخاصه بان فاجنير
سوف يتغير الكثير في بنيتها وفي رؤيتها
وبدا ذلك التغير اعلان الرئيس الروسي
مرسوما جديدا يكلف المؤسسات العسكريه ايا
كان نوعها باليمين باليمين يعني بان
الدوله الروسيه ستكون لها سلطه وقوه
مراقبه على المؤسسات الخصوصيه وخاصه التي
سبق عاش البلده تمردا هي صاحبته ليست فقط
مؤسسه مؤسسه عسكريه هي اول ما قبل كل شيء
مؤسسه اقتصاديه لانها تعمل وتستثمر في
استخراج واستغلال المعادن وخاصه المعادن
الثمينه مثل الذهب وكذلك النبض